what about your biggest splurges that
you feel comfortable shine I got a
Ferrari sf90 yeah I you know real estate
I don't know like for example I just
bought a Porsche uh uh turbo I don't
know what is a 911 turbo OS convertible
it's sick 2.2 seconds 0-60 but I bought
it because I fit in it well I'm 6'4 to
45 so for me I can't fit in the sf90 my
wife doesn't like to go on a date on the
sf9 even though she's tiny uh it's it's
a thousand horsepower car I bought it it
sat in the garage for uh uh I've driven
it maybe 10 times if you make a right
offer I'll sell it to you right now it's
like that's kind of where it's at with
that car yeah but my splurges I will in
a drop of a hat by million dollar
collectible card or spend a couple
million dollars on cars that to me if
you want to see me be 14 years old
childlike give me a great baseball card
and that happened today is what we were
looking at like 18 of them in the
morning
I would say for me it's more that uh
where I get excited about it cars really
what I will have one day I will have a
very high value car collection that has
a story behind it for example this car
was a gift given by Rolls-Royce to the
shop Iran that's for 28 million bucks I
want that you know this was the Porsche
that James Dean had that's this this I
want that this is the car that Churchill
whatever I want that those are the kind
of collections I want because history
drives me but all the others like having
a Bugatti or having this
just does literally nothing to me
foreign